i've been so healthy every day i'm like
taking all my vitamins
juicing and just trying to stay positive
kelly osbourne is bringing in a new year
of life with a whole new look
earlier this week the tv personality
celebrated her 36th birthday with a bash
at the yamashiro hollywood restaurant
to commemorate the big day sharon and
ozzy osbourne's daughter
rocked a stunning black cutout dress
that showed off her
impressive 85 pound weight loss she
looks
great and she's been skilled at all
almost she's like
she's unbelievable she can she listen
she can do anything cal accessorized the
look with a black face mask
emblazoned with an important message
vote the event featured a seriously
not safe for work cake and lots of
kelly's pals
oh and comedian donnie davis dressed up
as
president donald trump so
there's that back in august the former
reality star shared that she underwent
gastric sleeve surgery almost two years
ago
she stopped drinking and is focused on
living a healthier
lifestyle and all that led to shedding a
whopping 85 pounds i wake up
and in the morning and i guess it's what
i'm doing is intermittent fasting if you
were to think about it because
i get up i have coffee and then i juice
until night time and then i have
like one meal and then i go to bed back
in march etie caught up with kelly and
she revealed what she's been doing to
stay
fit while in quarantine i have so much
energy it's crazy i feel like i'm
bouncing off the walls
you get in quarantine and you're like
suddenly like becoming like fitness guru
and like
more energy and happier than you were
before quarantine i don't know it's the
weirdest thing i think that
i just like as they say went into action
rather than sitting here like
in fear yes queen you know it's a
commitment
kelly's commitment to fitness has been a
lifelong journey and she's been open
about it with fans over the years
in 2011 she opened up to shape magazine
about growing up in the public eye
and how being bullied because of her
weight ruined her self-esteem
i got sick and tired of everyone telling
me who i was
i wanted to take that power back and say
you know what this is who i am
and now kelly's proud to show off how
far she's come
back in august she shared this snap of
her new size during a shopping trip
alongside the caption yes i'm bragging
because i worked hard and it feels good
i am weird and wonderful
and different and content with myself
and that's enough